- To the point of the small influencers,
when I launched my book
and it's still something
we're doing now, what we
do it we go to Amazon,
look at what similar books
they recommend to mine,
so it's like 4-Hour
Workweek and Tools of Titans
and, ya know, all the other
entrepreneurship related books,
then we go to YouTube and
look up who's done a review
of these books and then we
reach out to each of them
individually and say,
"Hey, Evan has this book.
It's about this.
We saw you wrote about 4-Hour Workweek.
Would you like to do a
review of this book?"
And most people just do it for free.
I often --
- Do they do it though,
Do they do it because it's
you and you have a big channel
and they want to hope there's maybe
there's some reciprocity in the future?
I mean, could the average
Joe or Jill do what you did?
- It definitely helps.
Like we pick YouTube because I'm known
on YouTube in a niche, right?
Like I'm known for
entrepreneurs in YouTube.
I'm not like known by
everywhere on YouTube.
But I'm doing it there instead
of Snapchat or somewhere else
because I'm known in that community.
So, absolutely, I can do
that in a way that others
might have a harder time doing it.
But if you're an expert on leadership,
like they may resonated
with some of your messages.
You can still, like your
hit rate won't be as high
but it's still a viable
strategy to go with.
And some of them, like we'll
do a shout-out to some people
on some videos and say,
"Hey, thank you Jill
for profiling my book, go
check out her channel."
That kind of stuff.
And I also offer to be involved
on some of their videos.
It's like, hey if you
want something from Evan,
you want an intro, you
want to ask him a question,
you want something, I'll
make a prerecorded video
that they can use in their videos as well.
And so the bulk of our effort,
I have my assistant spend a lot of time.
Basically every week
she goes and does that
and looks at what are the
books that are related to mine,
which YouTubers have covered those books.
And then she'll reach out to them
and we have a constant stream
of channels of different sizes,
under a thousand subs
for a lot of them too.
Creating content, and then
I'll Tweet out the video
and I'll help promote it and,
like, they get some exposure
and there may be some
name-recognition with me
and they may not have any idea who I am.
But it's been affective in
getting the message out.
And it's something that
we consistently do.
- I'm wondering if everyone
picked up on something
that I did that Evan just
said, and that is he just
went around and knocked on
a bunch of YouTuber doors
and asked them to help
him promote his book.
I can count on one hand, and we've worked
with hundreds of brands,
how many of the brands
we've worked with have ever
even thought about doing that
or have done that.
They don't have to go
and pay us to do that,
they can do it themselves.
Now maybe they don't know how,
it's not that hard to figure out.
You don't have to hire us
to do something like that.
But at a minimum I'm thinking
if you got a new product,
if you're an entrepreneur,
what a great way
to get the message out about
your product or service,
even if you don't have a
huge channel like Evan does.
- Yeah.
For some people it's an honor.
Like for some people, I was
the first person to ever
reach out to them and offer something.
And then to be involved, to
have me involved in a video
and say something and to have
a shout-out on my channel.
You know it doesn't take a lot.
The exchange could be
we'll Tweet your video
from our account when it comes out.
- Or put it on our blog
or something.
- Right.
Yeah, I mean, and if you're a
brand, there's value in that.
And they can say we just
worked with Heinz or BMW
or whatever even though it was zero cost,
like you can leverage, just
like I'm leveraging my name
in the YouTube entrepreneur community,
my brand that's associated with it,
you could do the same thing.
People are now, some of
those people are saying,
"I collab-ed with Evan Carmichael."
And that makes them look better
for the next things they do.
So the brand, you can use that
to your benefit to help them
get more deals and you
don't have to pay anything.